certain colleges let's go down the list
here
ha these colleges have produced the most
billionaire alumni
okay wow so if you're looking for a
college and you're saying oh where
should i go to college maybe you start
with which colleges produces the
billionaires yeah good luck getting into
them good luck getting into this
good luck getting in shoot for the stars
right
um and uh some of them are the ones you
would suspect on this list and some
maybe not as much shoot for the stars
she'll land amongst community colleges
shoot for the stars and you'll land
amongst community college well played so
david uh
take a guess what is number one harvard
harvard
it is literally all right
in cambridge massachusetts they have so
this list is based on how many
billionaires not so much the amount that
these billionaires are worth but we're
going to give you those fun facts as
well and then hopefully you'll
understand okay a little bit more about
the colleges learn some stuff and i'll
give you some takeaways at the end so
number one is harvard with 29
billionaires who have graduated
from college 29 billionaires exactly so
these this list
is all who have graduated so it'll be a
fun fact here as well so alumni include
steve ballmer he was
uh one of the the ceo of microsoft at
one point he was bill gates replacement
for many now he owns the los angeles
clippers they can't get over the hump
but he's there going crazy you got the
winklevoss twins famous for you know
getting facebook stolen from them by
mark zuckerberg in harvard right so
they've since gone on to become crypto
billionaires
um and they've created gemini so i've
actually had the opportunity to have
dinner with those guys drinks of those
guys at the miami soho house those guys
are actually pretty cool don't be
shocked if you see them here on
valuetainment that's just a little heads
up we'll see wow um
yeah a little tease right there and then
you have lloyd blankfein he's the former
goldman sachs ceo goldman sachs arguably
the best investment bank in the world um
and then on top of that they're not
they're they're number one and they
don't even have two of the top five
richest people in the world on the list
and that's bill gates and mark
zuckerberg combined for 250 billion
dollars worth of net worth so com so
harvard's total net worth of
billionaires minus those two is 207
billion if you add those two they're
approaching
457 billion almost 500 billion dollars
that's harvard okay i'm a harvard man
exactly that's cambridge now number two
if i give you a list uh if i give you
ten guesses i don't know if you would
guess number two i really don't
it's not a bad school i mean it's a
fantastic school fiu fiu florida
international down here fau here in boca
that's not it the answer is
it's university of pennsylvania
in philly right you probably said yale
harvard stanford honestly
pennsylvania and you'll see the reason
why they have the second most number of
billionaires 28
and their total net worth which is one
of the largest on this list is
285 billion
and famous alumni include
former president donald trump and
current richest man on the planet elon
musk
elon musk and donald trump went to
college together not together there's
about 20 they're saying
they were roommates that's correct 20
years difference now of this 285 billion
of the exactly of this 285 billion elon
probably has 95 of that donald trump
probably has a couple billion but that's
number two on the list and the famous
business school
that uh people attend at penn is
wharton
wharton are you familiar with water i
went to water i went to water and i got
a business degree and now i'm with a
billion dollars congratulations now i
have student loans number three on this
list and thank you for um
for joining along with us right now
number three is none other than stanford
in california northern california
billionaires 28 same as
as pen however they have
150 billion dollars less so that's why
they're third on this list total net
worth
is 125
billion famous alumni include
co-founders of robin hood
big talk of the town that's vlad tenef
and baiju bot they've both graduated
from stanford um a lot in the news these
days robin hood i'm sure we have a lot
of fans or friends or followers a lot of
f's right there that um use robin hood
and then in addition to that there's the
co-founder of yahoo his name is jerry
yang these guys all went to stanford
numero
cuatro number four for our spanish
speakers out there is yale yale
university number four david for 10
billion dollars what state is yale
located in
uh connecticut oh my god
well played david well played david yeah
the answers to the test all along
all along did you know that or no
no
yale has 21 billionaires and they have a
total net worth of 140 billion dollars
the alumni include
uh mars
the heirs to the mars candy fortune the
mars family right so you're talking
about mars bars and i'm sure they own
like all the candy in the world whatever
they own they just probably their net
worth just increased substantially after
halloween um you have joe sai he is the
uh co-founder of alibaba
and then he's also the current owner of
the brooklyn nets
he went to yale he's a yale grad yes
huh huh do you know that and then in
addition to that you have a guy called
steven schwartzman
which i would like to call steve uncle
steve he's the ceo of blackstoners this
is basically the biggest investment firm
in the in the globe right now so blacks
so that is yale number five this is
coming out of left field typical
actually it's coming out of
east asia is
mumbai university in india you didn't
see that one coming did you no no
they're number five they produced 20
billionaires
india
yeah i only thought it'd be you thought
it was all just america
india taking over we're so worried about
china look at india
look at india producing billionaires uh
they have their most famous alumni is a
man called mukesh ambani one of the top
richest men in the world certainly the
richest man in india and quite possibly
the richest man in all of asia uh his
company is called reliance there are
conglomerate television
telecommunications oil manufacturing i
don't know what they don't do but number
five
is mumbai university of india we're now
at the top five on the list let's rattle
down the last five and let's get to the
point here number six is cornell my
business partner at my financial firm
went to cornell he loves talking about
how he went to cornell i said
you know how you know that mark
my business mark you know how we know
that mark went to cornell
because he was just full-on come out and
tell you i went to cornell and this is
why you should listen to me that's like
andy's in the office that's the whole uh
thing what do you say that's oh that's
his thing yeah he just constantly
reminds you that he's from we went to
cornell okay so there's a team here yeah
that's so funny i thought it was because
cornell isn't on the level of harvard or
yeah there i went that's him
um is it on the level of these
universities but they produce
billionaires so they feel the need to
just remind you that they also
are a uh ivy league school so cornell
university is in ithaca new york upstate
new york they've produced 18
billionaires not bad and they have a
total net worth of only 65 billion
dollars the rest of these guys have over
100 billion get it together cornell
famous alumni uh alumni include robert f
smith uh private echi is a private
equity guy
he might be
if not the richest one of the richest
african-american men in america robert f
smith he's had some hot water these days
tax evasion stuff i don't know what's
going on and then the newest person on
the entire billionaire list of these
universities is a guy called robert
langer and you recognize that name no i
don't either do i and either it's
probably most of america but this is why
we're going to pay attention to his name
he's a scientist with three percent
stake in a company called
moderna oh
i believe you might have been familiar
with the modernist shot these days uh
more familiar with the other one the
good one the pfizer the pfizer okay
but um
i know you have strong feelings on this
but basically he became a billionaire
this year because he was uh one of the
main scientists
at
cornell university in spanish harlem new
york you ever been there
no i haven't been to new york actually
i'm going for the first time why do i
ask you about new york you use the
british accent because i thought you did
one so i just copied i said you've been
in new york oh is that oh is that a new
york accent oh okay maybe not anymore
hey have you been to new york we've been
to new york
all right so that's number six number
seven um
is none other than ucla you didn't
expect that los angeles california
university of california los angeles i'm
not surprised though really
well wait do you hear who's on this list
15 billionaires worth 58 billion famous
alumni include
george lucas
the creator of yeah star wars yeah i
actually knew that not bad not bad
another guy who actually i think is a
great ceo his name is mark benioff he's
the
uh ceo founder of salesforce salesforce
now has merged with slack slack that
we're using here
boom you can thank ucla for that thank
you ucla
technically he didn't start um
slack but anyway you could i think yeah
well keep it stay on your toes buddy you
never know number eight number eight on
this list is the massachusetts institute
of technology commonly known as
mit you know how far harvard is from mit
they're both in massachusetts right how
you know
oh yeah yeah yeah how far do you think
uh i'm gonna go and say 10 miles they
are five minutes away from each other
like you could walk from harvard to mit
i didn't know that they're also in
cambridge so that concentration of
boston i got to tell you one of my best
friends we're going to talk about him
today huge in the crypto game huge in
the crypto game we're going to talk
about how i got into crypto how i got
into bitcoin some advice for you guys
out there he went to a little school
called tufts i'm like oh you think
you're a tough guy
that's like my thing with him but it's
also there in the boston area and it's a
great great school like ivy league maybe
below it
but the schools in boston are insane so
mit 14 billionaires with a total net
worth of 104 billion famous alumni are
the koch brothers you ever heard of the
koch brothers they own koch industries
the one of the private the the
wealthiest private um companies in the
country ridiculous i thought you're
trying to get me to narc for a second
but no i have not no koch the koch
brothers gotcha and then mo of more
recent fame is the
founder of ftx the crypto platform his
name is sam
bankman freed otherwise known as sbf you
ever seen this dude no dude
i grew up in miami i go to heat games i
have friends on the heat all that all
that all that my american airlines arena
he just came in crypto billionaire
status renamed the entire miami heat
american airlines arena 2
the ftx arena that's that's so fun
ridiculous you heard about it yeah yeah
why iota yeah why iota exactly i don't
know but this guy's a super genius right
here um
that's uh
mit for you all right super geniuses
over here uh number nine on this list
is columbia university in new york did i
say spanish harlem in in uh
for cornell no that's upstate new york
yeah colombia is what's in spanish
harlem a little further north uh new
york style my one of my best friends is
a dentist went there our uh robert hr
went to columbia this is how he went
yeah robert h.r does the guys have a
last name around here just robert h.r
they produced
11 billionaires with a total net worth
of 41 billion and their most famous
alumni
is the most winningest sports owner in
the nfl in the nfl and that would be bob
craft of the patriots oh all i do is win
win win no matter what except for when
tom brady goes to the buccaneers
it's no matter what so that's bad craft
and number 10 on this list
actually
um
is
princeton university fun fact right here
princeton is in new jersey
okay
11 billionaires but they have the most
amount of net worth on this list so they
have the least amount of billionaires
but they have the
largest net worth on this list and why
do you think that is david i don't know
because not only did jeff bezos go there
his wife or ex-wife mackenzie bezos went
there as well and they have a collective
net worth of however many hundred
billion dollars and that's why princeton
university has a full-on net worth of
288
billion dollars they shouldn't count his
jeff bezos wife's money in there because
that's jay besser
jeff bezos don't open up that can of
worms buddy she earned it they're chat
you to their way on to that list and
then a little uh
little bonus round for you number 11
because they were actually the same
amount of billionaires as princeton and
we'll just give a little shout out uh
cal berkeley uh up there in uh
berkeley land of california 11
billionaires 82 billion famous alumni
masayoshi son of softbank gordon moore
the co-founder of intel and if you like
the doordash there's the co-founder tony
u of doordash so anyway those are the
top schools that produce the top
billionaires all across the country
david here's the takeaway that i'm
taking give it to me here's the takeaway
now we talked about this before we
talked about making sure you pick the
right major for the right roi
when picking the college maybe you find
out
does it produce rich people
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken